ce weekend c'est pas et cette fête
religieuse s'accompagne aussi et surtout
peut-être de chocolat alors c'est un
marché qui se porte bien clcamb est allé
à la rencontre d'un artisan et d'un
responsable d'un rayon de
supermarché des poules des œufs ou
encore des fraises du chocolat sous
toutes ses formes Marie se consacre à
ses créations depuis un mois et demi
carapac la demande augmente et si les
classiques sont toujours les plus prisés
des créations un peu plus originales se
sont glissé dans la vitrine
pour attirer plus de clients toujours
une nouvelle clientèle aussi pour le
regard quand tout ça est en vitrine du
coup les gens sont intirés à rentrer
dans la boutique et cela semble
fonctionner car cette boutique ne
connaît pas la crise ici les
consommateurs sont de vrais amateurs de
chocolat mais la qualité a un coût ça
fait 110
60 il y a tro éléphants TR ass friture
pour limiter les dépenses Brigitte ne
réalise dans ce magasin qu'une partie de
ses achats de pâack pour les enfants
j'achète plutôt supermarché mais pour
les adultes je va j'achète plutôt en
chocolaterie ou en boulangcherie parce
que je trouve que c'est une meilleure
qualité effectivement au supermarché il
y a fou pour répondre à la demande un
rayon spécifique a été mis en place la
majorité des produits qu'on fait sur le
saisonnier sont des produits qu'on ne
fait pas le reste de l'année puis que là
c'est des moulages et les moulages on n
fait pas tout le reste de l'année donc
c'est vraiment une partie du rayon parc
qui est quasiment inexistence le reste
de l'année et qui là devient extrêmement
importante puisqu'on va vendre entre 350
et 400000 € de marchandises à peu près
100000 articles en l'espace de moins de
3 semaines 100000 ventes attendu car ce
supermarché observe en moyenne une
stabilité des dépenses quand cela
concerne les enfants mais dans les
rayons la vie est plutôt partagée si si
on fait attention euh moi je me fixe 10
€ voilà un paquet d'œuf et un gros voilà
et voilà ce qui fait à peu près une die
d'
oh non on on fait plaisirin non non on
limite pas on prend ce qu'on ce qu'on
voit ce qui est le mieux ce qui est sûr
c'est que tous les enfants partiront
lundi à la chasse aux œufs pâqu
représente 5 % de la consommation
annuelle de chocolat des Français nous
en mangeons 7 kg par
anve 7 kg par an évidemment pas que
c'est synonyme de gourmandise mais c'est
avant tout une fête religieuse c'est
même la fête la plus importante pour les
chrétiens rencontre avec le le Père
Mathieu Dupont Père Mathieu Dupont
bonjour merci de nous recevoir ici
devant l'église Saint-Martin de de
Montini magnifique église on va parler
avec vous de la symbolique de pâqu on
dit souvent que c'est la fête la plus
importante pour les chrétiens pourquoi
c'est une fête aussi importante on a
raison de dire que c'est la fête la plus
importante parfois on peut la mettre en
opposition avec Noël ou les rameau en
fait qu'est-ce qui se passe à pque
j'allais dire à PAC tout a changé il y a
2000 ans le Christ qui était mort et
ressuscité et ainsi le sens de
l'histoire a changé on n plus dans une
histoire fermée sur elle-même
l'ouverture de la la vie éternelle en
fait c'est réalisé et donc aujourd'hui
Pâques tout se pense à partir de Pâques
et même Noël est à comprendre en vue de
Pâques la fête de Pentecôte c'est la
continuité de pâqu donc le cœur de
l'année c'est pâqu pour les chrétiens
d'accord c'est une fête qui s'étale
entre le le jeudi saint et le dimanche
alors plus largement alors le le le jour
de pâqu c'est le dimanche de Pâques plus
précisément c'est même dans la nuit du
samedi au au dimanche de pâqu que nous
fêtons la résurrection puisque le Christ
selon la tradition manqu est mort un
vendredi le vendredi saint il est au
tombeau le samedi et le 3è jour donc la
nuit de samedi à dimanche et bien il
ressuscite il il retrouve la vie donc le
jour de pâqu c'est c'est dimanche plus
précisément la nuit de samedi à dimanche
la vigile pascale comme on l'appelle
mais c'est vrai que les fêtes de Pâques
commencent dès le jeudi jeudi saint ce
qu'on appelle le Triduum par Pascal
Triduum on voit 3 jours donc jeudi
vendredi samedi et puis dimanche matin
ou jeudi on va fêter l'institution de la
scène la scène c'est le repas que Jésus
a pris le dernier repas que Jésus a pris
avec ses apôtres où il a quelque part
inventé entre guillemets la messe ce que
nous célébrons chaque dimanche c'est ce
que Jésus a fait pour la première fois
le le jeudi le vendredi c'est donc le
jour traditionnel et bien des chemins de
croix on se souvient que Jésus a donné
sa vie il est mort pour nous et puis
donc le dimanche la résurrection donc
c'est vrai que ces trois jours saints
comme on les appelle sont liés mais
encore une fois le jour de pâqu c'est
celui de de dimanche alors ma question
ça concerne le lundi qui est férier
depuis en France en tout cas depuis le
le 8 mars 1886 alors pourquoi le lundi
est férier du coup que vous nous parler
de ses jours jusqu'à dimanche vous avez
pas parlé de lundi encore le Lund alors
le lundi il y a plusieurs raisons tout
d'abord la raison la plus simple c'est
que l'État a voulu offrir à cette époque
et bien un jour de de repos un jour de
fête un jour si je veux dire pour
continuer la fait le lundi de pâqu c'est
d'abord ça donc ça n'a pas une
signification chrétienne alors ça c'est
la première raison j'allais dire civile
mais la la raison on va dire chrétienne
c'est que pour les grandes fêtes Pâques
et Noël il y a ce qu'on appelle l'octave
qu'est-ce que c'est cloctave c'est 8
jours après la fête ou chaque jour c'est
la fête si vous voulez pâqu c'est
dimanche et puis lundi mardi mercredi
jeudi vendredi jusqu'au dimanche d'après
et bien pour nous chrétiens c'est encore
pas quelque part les les messes ont la
même faste alors bien sûr en semaine les
gens travaillent donc ils peuvent pas
toujours être présents mais le lundi
quelque part le le reste le relica et
bien de de cette fête qui continue
pendant 8 jours d'où le terme d'Octave
de pâqu tout à fait une autre question
alors concernant la date de ce dimanche
de pâqu de ce Lindi de pque c'est jamais
une date fixe au contraire par exemple
Noël on sait que c'est le 25 décembre
comment on fixe cette date d'abord qui
fixe cette date est-ce que alors en fait
fon de de quel calendrier alors
justement le jour de pâqu est fixé non
pas à partir du calendrier sola l' donc
qui ponctue nous notre année civile
c'est C 12 mois mais du calendrier
lunaire et le calendrier lunaire est
basé sur des cycle de 4 semaines de 28
jours et donc ce qui fait qu'il y a un
décalage en fait c'est en fonction de ce
calendrier là d'où et bien une date de
pâ qui oscile qui est toujours un
dimanche comme vous l'avez compris c'est
le dimanche que le Christ est ressuscité
mais qui est calculé non pas à partir du
calendrier solaire mais du calendrier
lire d'où ce décalage qui s'opère en
gros pâqu doit pouvoir être célébré vous
allevez me posé une pe si je sais moi
c'est entre ouais si je sais c'est entre
le entre le 22 mars et le 25 avril
voilàation là c'est c'est fin mars et je
en 2014 je regarde mes fiches hein c'est
le 20 avril ce sera le 20 avril en 2014
donc il y a quand même une oscillation
assez assez importante hein sachant que
peut-être sur ce point ce n'est pas
inscrit dans le marbre il est possible
le Concil Vatican 2 là ces évêques qui
sont rassemblés il y a 50 ans à Rome
pour ensemble reproposer la foi
chrétienne a ouvert la possibilité de
fixer le jour de pâqu un peu comme le
jour de Noël mais pas de le fixer je
dirais de notre propre initiative
catholique mais de le fixer en commun
avec les orthodoxes les protestants afin
de pouvoir célébrer le même jour et bien
ce jourlà donc c'est une possibilité
mais qui n'a pas encore été mise en
œuvre parce qu'on sa pas encore ver avec
le nouveau pape François peut-être
pourquoi pas faut aussi voir avec nos
frères orthodoxes et protestants on est
plusieurs sur c'est clair puisque c'est
une tête chrétienne il faut le il faut
le rappeler est-ce que c'est célébré
également chez les chez les juifs et les
musulmans pâac alors chez les juif euh
chez les Juifs oui voilà la Pâque juive
puisque la cette Pâque juive rappelle le
passage de la mer Rouge ce passage des
des Hébreux qui étaient en esclavage en
Égypte amené par Moïse là on a tous ces
images en tête là de du Prince d'Égypte
par exemple qui passe vers le le Sinaï
et puis la terre promise donc c'est ce
passage là que les Juifs faitent nous
quelque part nous fêtons un autre
passage c'est ce passage de la vie sur
Terre à la vie éternelle ce passage
passage du l'enfermement de la mort du
péché à la vie et donc c'est pour ça que
le terme de Pâque veut dire passage les
Juifs on voit que c'est évident ce
passage de la mer Rouge pour nous
chrétiens il y a aussi une forme
d'évidence c'est ce passage de la vie
terrestre à la vie éternelle et chez les
musulmans non les musulmans ne ne fêtent
pas le le jour de pâqu ils reconnaissent
Jésus comme un prophète mais ne le
reconnaissant pas comme le Fils de Dieu
ne reconnaissant pas aussi qu'il est
mort sur la croix cette fête leur est un
peu étrangère d'accord et donc présume
pour le dimanche de pâqu une affluence
particulière dans vos églises oui alors
une affluence particulière en fait
surtout le simpi soir ce qu'on appelle
la vigile pascale donc c'est dans la
nuit de de pâqu que cette que cette
vigile est célébrée et où l'ensemble de
la communauté paroissiale se rassemble
le jour de pâqu aussi mais il y a un
petit peu peut-être comme pour Noël o on
a plus habitude de venir à la veillée de
Noël et bien il y a cette habitude cette
belle tradition de venir surtout à la
vigile pascale le jour de pâ a une
affluence mais qui n'est peut-être pas
aussi grande que celle de la du samedi
soir en fait merci en tout cas Père
Mathieu Dupon d'avoir nous avoir
expliqué cette symbolique de pâqu merci
beaucoup écout merci à vous merci